[Música]
Ucrania anunció la liberación de 215
militares en un intercambio de
prisioneros con Rusia entre los cuales
se encuentran los líderes de la defensa
de la celiazo Hostal Rusia recuperó 55
prisioneros entre ellos el exdiputado
ucraniano Víctor medcet cercano habla de
mir Putin ya acusado de alta traición
porque
[Música]
continúan las protestas en Irán por la
muerte de maxam Mini tras ser detenida
por la policía de la moral las
autoridades reportan 17 fallecidos en
enfrentamientos con la policía mientras
que organizaciones no gubernamentales
cifran los decesos en 31
el Primer Ministro en funciones de
Israel Yair lápiz habló ante la asamblea
de las Naciones Unidas el líder defendió
la idea de dos estados para israelíes y
palestinos unas declaraciones que han
recibido el rechazo de los partidos de
derecha en Israel
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 y Rodrigo Sedán hoy es un
gusto acompañarlos abrimos esta emisión
con información sobre el intercambio de
prisioneros entre Rusia y Ucrania
mediado por Turquía entre los liberados
por el gobierno del presidente bolodimir
zelenski está el político prorruso y
cercano al kremlin Víctor mes de Chuck
detenido en kiev hace meses y acusado
por traición el intercambio incluyó a 10
extranjeros y a los comandantes que
dirigieron una prolongada defensa
ucraniana de mariu Paul a principios de
este año fueron en total 55 prisioneros
rusos canjeados por 215 ucranianos
después de meses de el sabor de la
libertad llega para algunos de los
soldados capturados por Rusia el
miércoles Ucrania anunció la liberación
de 215 militares en el mayor intercambio
de prisioneros desde el inicio de la
guerra
hoy tenemos 215 buenas noticias Esta es
definitivamente una victoria para
nuestro país y para nuestra sociedad
pero sobre todo para las 215 familias
que podrán ver a sus seres queridos
sanos y salvos en total 108 combatientes
del Batallón 188 Héroes de asoftal y
Mario Paul 8 que resultaron heridos
después del ataque terrorista ruso en
olenista
muchos de los liberados fueron
capturados durante el asedio de asoftal
incluidos 5 comandantes donde muchos
Soldados ucranianos del Batallón
resistieron durante semanas a las
fuerzas rusas en mariupol como parte del
acuerdo Ucrania liberó a 55 prisioneros
dentro de los que destaca Víctor
mevetshock ex legislador ucraniano y
estrecho Aliado de Putin de en abril fue
uno de los fundadores del partido Pro
ruso partido de la oposición por la vida
como resultado de un difícil proceso de
negociación 55 militares de las fuerzas
armadas de Rusia y las fuerzas de la
repúblicas de donex y lugans han sido
devueltos de los territorios ucranianos
controlados
estaban en riesgo mientras estaban en
cautiverio todos han sido transportados
en un avión militar a Rusia
en el intercambio también fueron
liberados prisioneros extranjeros
gracias a un acuerdo negociado con
Arabia Saudita 10 hombres aterrizaron en
riad el miércoles por la noche cinco
británicos dos estadounidenses un croata
un marroquí y un sueco uno de los
británicos Eden Slim Fue capturado por
fuerza respaldadas por los rusos en
abril y posteriormente condenado a
muerte al igual que el marroquí brahim
sudon capturado en donesk se espera que
todos los liberados regresen a sus
respectivos países en los próximos días
luego que el ejército ucraniano
anunciará la retoma de harkie fue un
equipo de investigadores llegó a un
pueblo de la zona donde encontraron los
que al parecer serían cuartos de tortura
France 24 acompañó al grupo de expertos
en una de sus pesquisas el informe a
continuación
en este pueblo de la región de harkif
justo en la frontera con Rusia Katherine
hpsova inspectora de la oficina local
está investigando junto con la policía
los presuntos crímenes de guerra de los
soldados rusos en contra de la población
ucraniana parte de este sótano sirvió
como cárcel está húmedo frío y apesta
orina
la gente fue retenida aquí para ser
torturada por eso ahora Estamos
inspeccionando el sitio junto con
investigadores expertos
revisa todo mira por todas partes Este
no es el único sitio de tortura que han
encontrado en cosechalopan los
investigadores se percataron de otros
similar con los bomberos de la zona
varios testigos dijeron a la policía que
el sótano de esta estación de tren Se
utilizaba como cámara de tortura el
equipo toma muestras de ADN de varios
objetos en el sótano para enviarlas a
analizar
durante nuestra inspección encontramos
cinta adhesiva y la estamos examinando
porque Probablemente lo usaron para
amarrar las manos de las víctimas
[Música]
este hombre de la localidad un antiguo
soldado ucraniano que pidió permanecer
bajo el anonimato pasó cinco días en el
sótano de la estación antes de ser
trasladado a otra prisión y sufrió
tratos inhumanos a manos de las tropas
rusas
[Música]
uno de ellos me interrogó sobre mi
servicio y mi puesto en el ejército me
bajó los pantalones y me dijo que me
acostara horizontalmente tomó una pinza
de hierro y la sujetó a mi pene dijo
responderás Después de cinco descargas
eléctricas Estaba tratando de golpear mi
cabeza contra la pared yo solo gritaba
fue horrible
dice que se siente aliviado por la
presencia de los investigadores aliviado
pero aún roto
reunidos en el Consejo de Seguridad de
la ONU por primera vez desde que comenzó
la invasión de Ucrania el canciller ruso
serguéi rechazó las acusaciones
occidentales sobre Ucrania Mientras que
el secretario de estado estadounidense
Anthony blinken dijo que Rusia no puede
salirse con la suya vamos a permitir al
presidente Putin que se salga con la
suya en este caso defender la integridad
territorial y la soberanía de Ucrania es
mucho más que defender el derecho de un
país solo sino que hablamos también de
proteger el derecho internacional donde
ningún país se puede modificar las
fronteras de otro por la fuerza sino
defendemos este principio que cuando el
kremlin lo está violando claramente
estamos mandando un mensaje a otros que
también lo pueden ignorar y todos los
países estarán en riesgo abrimos la
puerta a un mundo menos Pacífico menos
seguro el término impunidad se refleja
lo que ha venido ocurriendo en el país
desde 2014 de fuerzas nacionales
radicales
que ocuparon el poder Entonces como
resultado de un golpe armado con apoyo
de los países occidentales y entonces se
dedicaron a la ilegalidad y a la
negación de los derechos de las
libertades el derecho a la vida el
derecho a la expresión el derecho a
acceder a la información y el derecho a
utilizar la lengua materna
los crímenes en maidane en febrero de
2014 siguen impunes entre tanto miles de
ciudadanos rusos intentan salir del país
luego del anuncio de movilización a
300.000 hombres reservistas que el
miércoles hizo Vladimir Putin la guardia
de fronteras finlandesa informó de un
aumento del 57% de rusos que intentaron
cruzar por carretera alguno de los nueve
puntos fronterizos que comparten los dos
países otras fronteras como las de
Georgia kazajistán y mongolia también
han visto aumentado el tráfico de rusos
desde Rusia rechazan estas informaciones
y las tildan de exageradas
al tiempo las provincias de Luján
sidoniesca avanzan con los preparativos
para los referendos de anexión a Rusia
que tendrán lugar entre el 23 y el 27 de
septiembre este jueves el jefe de la
comisión electoral de la autoproclamada
República Popular de donies que Vladimir
bistowsky inspeccionó varios colegios
electorales que aseguró están preparados
al cien la televisión Estatal rusa
emitió un reportaje en donde se veían
también los preparativos en la región de
lugans con la entrega de las primeras
papeletas electorales
y nos vamos hasta Irán las protestas por
la muerte de maxa Mini dejan ya 17
personas fallecidas según informó la
televisión Estatal sin embargo
organizaciones no gubernamentales las
cifran en 31 a mini murió bajo custodia
policial tras ser detenida por la
policía de la moral por presuntamente
utilizar mal su velo que hoy fue
sancionada por Estados Unidos el
presidente del país ebrain raízzi afirmó
hoy que se está investigando la muerte
es un incidente que está siendo
investigado y que se atribuye a lo que
le ocurrió a la dama lo que se está
hablando hoy de lo que se ha hablado con
respecto a su muerte si hay una parte
culpable ciertamente debe ser
investigada me puse en contacto con su
familia La familia de la difunta les
asegure personalmente que continuaremos
firmemente investigando ese incidente
una nueva catástrofe humanitaria solo el
Mediterráneo al menos 34 personas
migrantes murieron en costas sirias
mientras viajaban a bordo de una balsa
desde el Líbano se trata de uno de los
peores incidentes ocurridos desde que se
ha popularizado la ruta migratoria desde
el Líbano según el testimonio de un
superviviente a la televisión pública
Siria en torno a 150 personas viajaban
en la balsa y se calcula que aún quedan
en torno a 100 desaparecidos
Mientras tanto Avanza en Nueva York la
tercera jornada de la edición número 77
de la asamblea general de la ONU uno de
los líderes mundiales en pronunciarse en
el que es considerado el evento
diplomático más importante del mundo fue
el primer ministro en funciones de
Israel Yair lápiz entre otros temas
abordó el conflicto israelí palestino y
la actividad nuclear de Irán económico
la fuerza económica y militar de Israel
permite protegernos pero también nos
permite algo más
la posibilidad de luchar por la paz por
todo el mundo árabe y con nuestros
vecinos más cercanos los palestinos
un acuerdo con los palestinos basado en
la idea de dos estados es lo correcto
para la seguridad la economía y el
futuro de nuestros niños
los judíos de hoy tenemos un estado un
ejército amigos sobre todo Estados
Unidos
Y tenemos la capacidad y no tenemos
miedo de utilizarlas haremos lo que sea
necesario Irán no tendrá un arma nuclear
no vamos a quedarnos de brazos cruzados
cuando sabemos que nos pueden matar
volteados
las palabras de Lápiz sobre la solución
de dos estados ha provocado la era de
los líderes de los principales partidos
de derecha en Israel algunos de los más
vehementes fueron los ex primeros
ministros naftalí bennett y benjamina
tan Yahoo Quien escribió lo siguiente en
su perfil de Twitter no permitiremos que
Yair la pide establezca un estado
palestino y que nos devuelva al desastre
de oslo y en México este jueves se
registró un nuevo sismo de 6,9 grados
una réplica del terremoto del lunes de
7,4 grados que ya se ha cobrado la vida
de al menos dos personas y ha dejado
daños en el Estado de Michoacán Alba
Santana tiene los detalles
como una historia que se repite México
registrar un terremoto en el Estado de
Michoacán esta vez de magnitud 6,9 de
nuevo el sismo como a la
1:20 de la mañana en mitad de la noche
sorprendió a los mexicanos cuando ya
estaban dormidos obligando a muchos a
evacuar envueltos en mantas
y me levanté posteriormente empecé a
escuchar la letra sísmica
salí corriendo
fuerte Este es el segundo terremoto que
vive el país en menos de una semana algo
que tiene una explicación científica se
trata de una de las réplicas del sismo
de 7.7 grados del lunes que son
movimientos en las placas tectónicas
para reacomodarse y volver a su estado
original tras el terremoto inicial hasta
las 8 a.m del 22 de Septiembre se han
registrado 1.365
réplicas del sismo de magnitud 7,7
ocurrido en Michoacán el 19 de
septiembre la más grande fue de magnitud
6,9
aunque esta vez no hay alerta por un
posible tsunami los sismos han causado
estragos para los ciudadanos muchos
edificios y casas han sufrido daños como
en el caso de la agricultor Roberto
Verduzco que se encontró su casa en
ruinas claro
no siente más cosas No más de que se va
a acabar el mundo además de los años
materiales el terremoto también se ha
saldado con varios muertos y el miedo a
que se vuelva a repetir cerramos en El
Salvador en donde este jueves se
reportaron al menos siete fallecidos a
causa de los deslizamientos de tierra
causados por las Fuertes lluvias de las
últimas horas las autoridades de
Protección Civil anunciaron que cinco de
estas personas fallecieron en la
localidad de huizucar en el centro del
país según este organismo en septiembre
las lluvias han dejado al menos 160
desplazamientos 38 viviendas dañadas y
16 Ríos desbordados
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
conectados a France 24 y Recuerden que
pueden ampliar toda esta y mucha más
información en nuestro sitio web
france24.com
[Música]